[Music]
I'm an IT networking engineer with on
Prem experience and my company has
recently joined Google Cloud I need to
create and modify a virtual private
cloud or VPC with dual stack subnets in
my company's new Cloud environment so
that we can continue to run our business
smoothly with a hybrid Cloud approach
I'm fairly new to the cloud in general
but I've been told that duet AI can help
me create this VPC using g-cloud the
command line tool for Google Cloud
without needing much previous Cloud
knowledge to start I'll ask duet AI some
questions to get a better understanding
of how things work in Google Cloud to
prompt duet AI I can click the duet AI
button at the top right corner of the
console to open up the
[Music]
chat and write my prompt directly here
in natural language I know that I
already have a primary private domain
name system or DNS resolution on PR but
I want to know if it's possible to
integrate it with Google Cloud DNS so
I'll ask do at AI how DNS forwarding
Works between Google cloud and on
premises
servers cool it's telling me that Google
Cloud DNS can forward queries to on
premises DNS servers and vice versa so
my on premises DNS servers can forward
to Google Cloud DNS which is what I
need my next question is around the Dual
stack subnet requirement I imagine I can
use ipv4 and IPv6 subnets in Google
Cloud but I want to double check before
I move forward again I'll ask duet if I
can use both ipv4 and IPv6 subnets in
Google
cloud and yep it tells me that I can use
both and a VPC Network can contain any
combination of these subnet types now
that I have my questions answered let's
get into actually creating this VPC I
know I want to use g-cloud to create the
VPC so I'll give duet that context in my
prompt so how can I use g-cloud to
create my first VPC Network in Google
[Music]
cloud and duet gives me a response with
the steps that I need to take it gives
me the initial command to create the VPC
and then a follow-up command to create a
subnet in the VPC
Network this is a good start and these
seem like pretty easy steps but I just
realized that I didn't specify that I
want dual stack subnets so instead of
retyping my prompt with that edit I'm
going to ask a follow-up question about
adjusting the command that was just
provided so let's say like how can I
adjust the g-cloud command provided to
create a subnet to ensure sure that it's
dual
[Music]
stack du gives me a
response and I can see
here that the stack type flag specifies
that the subnet should be dual stack
this is helpful because duet was able to
use the context from the previous
interaction to follow up which saves me
time now that I know how to make my
Subnet dual stack I can start with the
commands provided to create my
network so first I'll open up the
g-cloud CLI by clicking this button on
the console
[Music]
toolbar then I can run the First Command
I was given to create a network VPC
making sure to replace network name with
the name that I want for my
[Music]
network and I can click enter to run
it great and I can see here that my VPC
was
created next I'll create the dual stack
Subnet in my VPC Network by running the
other command I was provided this time
I'll need to replace the subnet name
network name access type typ subnet
range and
[Music]
region nice and just like that my VPC
and subnet have been created if I wanted
to make additional subnets I can just
repeat this step so that was actually
pretty easy with the help of do at AI I
was able to find helpful networking
information for Google cloud and how to
create VPC without having to leave the
console and with really minimal
knowledge of Google
Cloud check out the documentation Linked
In the description to use du a
assistance yourself to design a
network